hey guys my name is Jess McDonald a to
the eighth of April today and you're
watching games but news JS x mankind
divided dropped its very first trailer
today and a bevy of new info so here's
everything you probably want to know
sporanox unveiled the mood ECG trailer
which contains an awful lot of guns
cybernetic tech and vague narrative info
which suggests protagonist Adam Jensen
has a whole mess of new problems to deal
with this time around publisher Square
Enix have also confirmed that the game
will run on the jawn engine will feature
Direct X 12 support as well as AMD's
tressfx wavy hair technology to quote
not only raise the bar in game
performance but bring unrivaled visual
fidelity to the Deus Ex franchise
mankind divided will be continuing the
story of Adam Jensen prompt human
Revolution and you can check out that
full fancy trailer on gamespot know
Spencer has had some things to say about
the xbox one today concerning the
improvements are hoping to make to the
console the head of Microsoft's Xbox
division we're speaking to fans on
Twitter and said that they want to
create a more fluid and quick user
interface adding that the xbox dashboard
will be able to take full advantage of
the upcoming Direct X 12 programming
interface DirectX 12 was first announced
back in March last October Phil Spencer
said that while it will affect the xbox
one it will likely have a subtle impact
as opposed to an extensive one it seems
that despite the Grand evolution of
video games not everything changes
according to a new report has suggested
that GTA 5 PC is going to ship on 7 DVDs
if you are planning to grab the physical
version of the game you may want to
clear your schedule for an afternoon of
discs changing when the game launches on
April 14 take this info with a grain of
salt as it's not been confirmed by
Rockstar although an image of the
multitude of discs did appear on reddit
earlier today the pc version of 2008 GTA
4 shipped on just two dvds but that game
was 16 gigabytes compared to
GTA 5 65 gigabytes so this could totally
turn out to be true let me know down in
the comments if you prefer to buy your
games in physical or digital form and
why you can have the game spot where
we've got news on battlefield hardlines
boss leaving EA and the xbox one new TV
service that is all the stuff that I've
got for you today as always leave your
comments down in that comment box and
I'll catch you again tomorrow